hi guys um yeah so one of the reasons
we're doing these videos is just to
simplify what we're doing with the gajim
Maru and our blockchain system um so one
of the questions I was going to ask to
Craig is um why gar what's the name
about oh right yeah so the name's a
little bit of a mouthful uh gajim M when
I was first writing out um we knew we
had to partition the system uh to to get
train activity more local so activity
over here wasn't affecting activity over
there uh typical distributed systems
kind of designed but doing that in the
context of a blockchain is very
challenging so the idea of a central
mint that's proof of work press so you
could have your coinbase protected
without we perverse incentives emerging
which happens elsewhere um but then have
other side chains that could use the
common currency that's trust commonly
trusted and I couldn't decide when I was
trying to describe a system like this I
couldn't think what to call it and you
know fortunately for me I I live in
Japan Southern Japan and we have a tree
there's one outside my office a a tree
called the gajim mo which means like the
walking tree and it there's a it starts
with a single bowl and then it kind of
drops off these Runners that become they
look like trees on their own and you
can't tell which one was the original
one at some point um and I was like oh
God that's a cool name so it it's a
working name um I thought we would
change it later nothing better came up
so it stuck so that's what we got uh as
far as how that plays out in terms of
the technical side like how does the the
mint that the original one talk with
these side chain these associate chains
um deitar has been working on actually
implementing that uh so he could maybe
elaborate yeah uh so those uh chains
those size chains we call them associ
chains and they're
specific for different use cases so you
want to have a business case that relies
on a blockchain You Spa your own
associate chain and this associate chain
will obey the rules that you embeded in
uh for example it can be proof of work
or proof of State Pro Authority it could
be permiss if you want to uh it's going
to be serving your particular needs uh
you can adjust its consensus to meet
your actual
needs uh this allows you to have your
own uh transaction po Reserve just for
you so you don't have to rely on other
businesses not overflowing the
transaction pool the blockchain that
happen to different
blockchains and uh how this ties to the
whole ecosystem I ask helping well
actually de you were asking uh you were
making good points around this in the
past that um one of the things that you
can do with the associate chains and the
specific way you can design them is you
can avoid a lot of the issues that we've
seen around uh people essentially
bribing nodes or miners to to get output
so I mean talk to that a bit further oh
this has happened numerous times of
different blockchains when there is an
application that gains a lot of momentum
uh a lot of people start using it and
since the trans pool if it is shared is
quite limited always uh then the co m is
flooded with transactions and then
miners have to pick which transactions
to get included in a
block uh and what they do is uh each
transaction comes with a p and they pick
the ones that provide the most fees the
fees goes to the Min that includes the
transaction with the blockchain uh so
people start increasing the fees to
bribe them uh the computational work
that is being done for this transaction
is not more than it used be last last
week but since there are more
transactions you are paying for your
memory space in the block and if you
have your own transaction TR that's
reserved for your particular use case uh
that
takes uh congestion caused by other
projects so it it's really recognizing
that different use cases have different
requirements around all of these points
but also allowing us to say you know
there needs to be an understanding of
the common resource which is the the
mint and really trying to make that as a
effective as it can be as a common
resource whilst enabling specific
utilization to be in the associate
chains and actually that's not where the
to the point that you were making just a
second ago that's not where it it ends
there are major interplays between the
associate chains and the mint that are
really important to the security and
operation of both so that is 's
baby yeah and uh so the the ecosystem
part of the G aru the sort of the
nutrition that flows through the entire
system is the gaju the common currency
that is minted on the main chain through
uh proof of work Mining and uh one of
the rules we impose is
that your account identity and
signatures will be valid on every
account so that you can when you spawn
an associate chain you essentially check
out G juice from the mint you can
transfer G to and from the mint uh
between the mint and your associate
chain and you can also transfer Gus uh
between chains um this also creates a
competitive space so that if like dier
described a chain gets overloaded or uh
doesn't serve uh a use case properly
then you you can actually spawn a
competing chain where the common the
shared resources can flow because you're
not locked into the unique currency of
the specific chain that you decided
to uh uh to start on and uh so and
also uh for this to work the we believe
that the mint needs to be a full
capacity or high-capacity full featured
blockchain where that you could actually
run your applications on to begin with
it will be an unregulated space a fully
decentralized blockchain and um then as
you need to Branch into or or adapt to a
regulated space for your real business
then you can do that on on an associate
chain now the associate chains will also
cooperate to uh improve the finality as
we call it on the the mint we will get
back to that with slightly more details
uh afterwards um and
uh yeah this is a deep well that we
can't really get into now the um thing
about how to enable this whole economic
ecosystem is
um it's been really valuable to have
Peter uh along as a rubber duck and uh
and to try to answer his questions and I
will let Peter talk a little bit about
more about
that yes one of one of the complications
I had when I got into this industry was
there's so many layers of complexity on
the technical side and economical side
so I mean what we're doing here is
trying to really break down these videos
into small chunks and help people along
so even the naming convention just help
people understand why we've designed and
developed the purpose behind the gajar
and the simplification of it so everyone
can participate so keep coming back to
watch our videos um and hopefully you
get a better understanding and you want
to join in and
participate yeah so you know one of the
things that I think has been very
interesting with Peter and and um both
explain it well is as we've been talking
through these things in in the group um
Peter's been asking questions that you
he says I'm sorry this is this may seem
an obvious thing but what about this and
the answer is usually ah you know the
reason why you don't understand is
because you're uh to to paraphrase Greg
you're a good person who's thinking of
this logically and and the the answer
tends to start with there's so much
disinformation in here that ultimately
what this industry as a whole has been
trying to do is saying okay we've got a
couple of squares that we've attached to
axles on this new mode of
Transport um and instead of saying well
squares aren't very good Wheels they've
instead tried to turn them into polygons
pun intended um
and obscure the fact that actually the
original design just didn't work and
hide that behind a lot of complexity and
you know very dense technical
explanations that most people really
can't get into and and that's exactly
what we're trying to challenge with
these videos we're trying to make it so
that people can understand some of the
design decisions the motivations
ultimately we're trying to create an INT
of economics and what that means is that
we have an open common resource layer
that is this gajim Maru and that's what
we're trying to deliver to the market so
as Peter says stay tuned for more videos
and thank you for your time bye-bye